[Music]
all right who wants
to travel a million dollars you know i
[ __ ] doors
[Laughter]
where would you like to travel
everywhere i want to go to oh me and
nadeem
we're gonna go live in the uk for a
month nice
you heard that the food is really good
one better two beds two
one no together and mike is coming too
huh he's allowed him maybe i mean if he
wants to yeah oh yeah he's a little bit
just being you i like their head they're
like a couple they're like asking him
from information
who's big spoon i'm no i'm big schools
i'm big spoon can't lie
i mean i i am sometimes no no
and then um we want to use
because like there's a lot of flights
out of london so london has like [ __ ]
20 airports right
right so it and it's extremely cheap so
london will be the hub
you know because it's like english and
it's just easy that's easier to get
around and we found a spot where
uh basically you could rent it out and
then the more days you rent it out the
cheaper it gets
oh and then we can have like luxury
three bedroom apartments for like if we
split it three ways it's like a grand
each wait so you guys are for real like
you actually really
planned it out for 2021 if we can do it
nice and then
from there uh instead of being in like
london for a whole month
we'll just fly out to like different
countries for a few days
airbnb and then come back that's cool
yeah man
living in london you're backpacking
through london or uk
yeah pretty much or train or whatever
that's dope
and then um yeah and i definitely want
to go back to the vietnam's my friends
out there you know he's like got a new
house and he's like we got extra rooms
just stay
you know hawaii you know i gotta i gotta
go all over this there's people waiting
for me you know like
it's quarantined man what the [ __ ] he's
holding you back that's true would you
ever go to a place called
uzbekistan yeah i know where that is
where that says
it's right next to kazakhstan oh it's
true it's one of the stands i'm not
gonna go anywhere
true but uzbekistan is like one of the
most corrupt countries in the whole
entire world so i'm scared in an entire
world really oh [ __ ]
you have a lot of uzbeki fans actually
really
how do you know because uh in another
episode we talk about uzbekistan
i guess they said joe said something
incorrect but it wasn't because i
checked what you're talking about
um i think they're just mad which you
shouldn't be uh but they're like hey i'm
from
this place and you said that do all the
stands have a connection
afghanistan from afghanistan
uzbekistan kazakhstan that didn't
connect
to kyrgyzstan yeah i do all the stands
go stan's pride
do you understand do you not like if you
meet someone from like kazakhstan or is
becca said do you feel like uh they're a
little bit closer to you
because of like is it culturally this
might have a similar culture i love all
human beings all right all
[ __ ] [ __ ] dead culture though like
kind of like how like
i don't know the religions like when i
when i visit korea i'm like oh it's
like east asians kind of similar yeah
i'm like it's all kind of connected
with latin countries yeah like mexico
split then like fill that with
yeah like in boot camp it's like one
asian and another one right and even
though the other asian is like a weird
one like filipino or something i go
oh weird one you just called all
filipinos weird
and we have a we have a name well he buy
these i'm weird i stand up for my
filipinos right they're spanish but
we're the closest yeah they're our
cousins but we're the closest
and [ __ ] ding ding ding ding ding and
it's like
i was wondering if like the stands are
like that i feel like we see each other
and we're like
yeah shit's rough out here right and
like yeah i don't know why so there's no
closer connection
closer maybe yeah there's a there's like
a yeah
where does it start is similar i think
it's like pakistan afghanistan
so like we're south asians uzbekistan
kazakhstan that's another one what how
many other stanzas
there's a gurgley stand too right in the
middle it's a it's a
it's a stance dance man yeah what the
[ __ ]
you said it with but it's like it's
weird because we're like
we're like kind of like i said like
we're in central asia but like i've got
so afghanistan
where it's like we're technically i'm
not even middle eastern i'm south asian
i just found that out i guess oh really
yeah but like um
you look a little aren't you are you you
mean
you're middle ages do you guys have
pita and hummus that's the rule no then
that's one culture
oh yeah i'm not no it's not
is it that's how the u.n classifies it
yeah yeah the union is like
okay olives falafel
oh loves because i'm thinking like
greece i love all of you yeah that's all
that greek food mediterranean yeah not
middle eastern i know
yeah so i'm like no it's not so the
article yeah
oh yeah so he forgot and i was like
so bad with geography all right so just
to give you a little taste of uzbekistan
oh that's gorgeous it's [ __ ]
beautiful
very very beautiful a little bit a lot
of blue like right here it kind of
reminds me of
istanbul i want to go to uzbekistan i
was like assemble or something
[ __ ] how did i do this maybe don't say
that
maybe don't say that
that's pretty funny though and that's
the p they look almost
asian to me because they are a lot of
the stands are very eurasian
hot even the guys we have like uh we're
like [ __ ] blood in us
yeah yeah yeah yeah there's like
mongolian with the rashes there's so
many hapas but they don't call them
hapa's over there because that's the
that's the bloodline now and it's like
the official like
ethnic group oh so uzbekistan now
is trying to reopen its economy by uh
giving giving any visitor who wants to
visit
three thousand dollars well but this
will
yeah so it's 3 000 american dollars i'm
assuming don't lie
so yeah so uh you know like the world
doesn't want americans right now though
i think they're just trying to jumpstart
their economy so they'll like let's take
it all so they're like they're gonna
spend it all here anyway so
here's three thousand dollars get your
ass over here but they don't know that
they're right next to china and you know
what's gonna happen
chinese people are gonna be like [ __ ]
yeah baby i'll go there and i go right
back home
true true yeah the caveat of this whole
thing is that
uh not every country is open to their
three thousand dollars uh and that
includes us
uh in the uk and most in all of europe
uh they're required we're required to
quarantine for 14
days what if they're like only rich
people because
we don't want you poor people coming in
and taking three thousand going home
oh true but then if they're poor then
then they like
how do they even get there to begin with
huh
they have to have some money why don't
they just give the money to their people
in no i think they're trying to
stimulate their economy so there's an
incentive for people to go
to go and spend money there you go if
they were going to pay me 2 000 and go
and have a blast that'd be dope to me
that's like a casino where you go like
right now vegas got a lot of deals
they're like we got free rooms
we'll give you not only free rooms but
50
hotel credit that you use in the slots
that's 50
free play that's it yeah but they know
once you play
you're to spend like 50 dollars a person
that's like a lot
well uh 50 could go a long way if you go
to the quarter slots
which is true or the penny slots yeah oh
[ __ ] i
actually reported it wrong oh where did
you [ __ ] up uh with the 3
we're the only media outlet that
corrects herself so what is that true
i was like oh this seems like an easy
article so i'll just kind of skim it and
i
[ __ ] up my studio 100 000 no
it's 3 000 oh but they're giving 3 000
for
any visitor who gets infected huh
infected by what oh by clovis you want a
gamble
come over here we're so sorry i'm here
come here we're so safe but if you get
sick
we'll pay your ass exactly because
that's right oh that's a good
one kronos virus and they did a really
swift lockdown they only had 19 reported
uh down wow 18 deaths wait but how many
out of 33 million people living in the
country i don't know how many cases they
got
if i go there i want to go there with a
positive result
yeah yeah somebody the deep cough on me
all right let's go
and then like right when you get home
you got it no but if you had it
[ __ ] coffee not personally offended
so you cough on me used in this example
wait that seems wrong and then we go
there and it takes five
days for it to show up on a test and
then you go you're
oh i'm [ __ ] sick dude i mean i
actually probably will be really sick
and then you get the coronas and you get
three thousand dollars yep
but they want they probably want you to
to prove that you got it in the country
yes and that's why people from the uk
and europe need a quarantine for 14 days
when they arrive so that they know
that they thought about your coronavirus
it's from
them and not from their home places
save it ah wait it doesn't work like
that no no that's it for the sake it
does
wait what if you cough in a bag and just
keep there it's not gonna i don't know
man i actually don't
wow the floor is not lava nadine no but
i just said they brought it back up i i
i dismissed it as my negativity i didn't
hear you the first time around i don't
want corona
it wasn't even a joke i don't think
that's funny you don't joke around
with stuff like that that it wouldn't
survive that way oh yeah it wouldn't
survive that way
i don't i don't know um yeah i don't
know i don't want corona
okay but what's the purpose of that so
the purpose is to uh
open back uh uzbekistan back up for
traveling and to
stimulate the economy because i think
are they like an evil
country that's like hey we're going to
open back up everyone come together then
go back to your countries and
no i think what they're doing is kind of
like hey do you see how great we are
come to our country like almost like
bragging rights
we guarantee there's no way you're gonna
get it if you do we'll pay you
you're not gonna get it and if you do
we'll pay you it's not saying come get
it
no no no they're bragging that we are
[ __ ] safe
we handle this coronavirus [ __ ] like a
gangster prove them wrong
they're not allowed allowing us for it
to go true so so the countries that are
uh
look they want low-risk countries to go
and ironically china's part of that list
china israel japan south their numbers
are low no i mean like oh so uh
are they talking about we don't let
people come in geographically from
america or people with an american
passport
i don't know i don't know i actually i
mean you could totally lie and say like
i've been in europe this whole
time with an american passport but they
don't want uk people either uk and
europe
you need a quarantine you go there and
quarantine for 14 days go to libya
and i'll say i've i've been from libya
yeah i've been out here
true that's how i be cheating another
caveat
uh with this whole three thousand dollar
deal is that you must
book with a local tour guide so you have
to be on one of those like buses
where they take you around is you have
to do their program you can't just go
there they're going to scheisse your
3000 first this is
a building with a blue tower this is our
other building with the blue floor
how much is that how much does the
touring thing cost three
two
[Laughter]
they're like oh come here we have the
best seafood and we're like oh i guess
so we go there like
i thought mexico seafood would be good
why this one's all nasty yeah
i know man i had something too and they
were like oh the
the drink package it's only gonna be
this amount
didn't [ __ ] tell us it was that
amount per day that we were there
oh yeah and i'm like yeah we ended up
drinking way more we're like
i don't wanna drink all because it's
free you have to pay
well it wasn't free we paid for that
package which was it i don't remember
but it was just like like the initial
amount we're like oh that sounds like a
great deal but then
they forget to inform us that that's the
amount per day that we're there
maybe we need to get on a billionaire's
yacht and experience what that's like
yes do you know any billionaires i'm
working on it we're taking acid on a
inflatable yeah that's kind of one two
if we take acid
on an inflatable raft they really want
us to do a dmt on camera i wouldn't do
it all at the same time
let's start with weed first yeah true
let's do weed
like for dmt that's that's such a like
internal
experience that i wouldn't want to film
it how about uh
we eat an apple for you guys with dmt in
it
acid on it do you have an apple yeah i
ate half of an apple earlier you guys
want to share it
no you gotta sign up for patreon for
that one
[Music]
so